[Music]
sexiest man alive is definitely not
Patrick and this is why yeah
it's not exactly what I thought it'd be
be humble house it'll be called be
humble probably high times and that's in
two fashions because I was hired they
are high five
it would win a Nobel Peace Prize and the
Oscars life on the beach I love the
beach
the title of the book would be called
you cannot bring your Pico to heaven ten
pounds of [ __ ] in a five-pound bag the
black sheep smoke weed every day
when's he gonna fold because I go
through a lot of challenges a lot in my
life my family and all that and they
just keep coming early I don't think
I've folded yet
an athlete's journey friends and family
this is the choices I've made it would
be if I knew I was going to live this
long I took better care of myself
Jill of all trades like that oh [ __ ]
that's it the title the movie oh [ __ ]
but in a good way though and a good way
oh [ __ ] not like ocean in a madman
it'd be a book and Gone with the Wind
the rise living life and living it right
the undiscovered choosing the right path
it would be a book and each page kind of
writes itself
how to deal with the stepparent a trip
it be
it'll be a book sleek I'm always adding
it through
do as I say not as I do the title would
be hard work you can do what you believe
it's all about the love the forests of
the world ice age
one first word that came to mind
there's no reason behind it nothing has
reason honestly okay would it be a
Booker movie it'd be a boobie boobie
basically you open it and the movie
plays out in front of you but you have
to turn the pages for the story to
progress
[Music]